hey everybody its Jesse and streaming a
little bit earlier than normal today I
have a meeting at my normal streaming
time so it's actually my lunch break now
which obviously I'm not taking today but
it's also gonna be kind of a shorter
stream so since I have a meeting in an
hour and a half I want to try to keep
this to about an hour to give me enough
time I'm actually gonna walk over and
meet with people face to face today so
I'm not gonna meet um you know via my
computer but yeah like I normally do and
usually prefer to do so hopefully you
know look you all got my message on
Twitter so sorry for changing up the
times on you
the last stream and this stream
hopefully tomorrow we'll be able to
stream at the normal time so a lot has
happened with the project since the last
stream and Wow
the analytics just jumped like from like
7 to 57 all right so let me catch you up
as quickly as I can on what's changed
and then let's try to get as much of the
rest of the layout done so then we can
actually start working on something a
little bit more interesting so we got
some some form data that we have to
handle and uploads and we got to work
with an API for a project management
system so we have some some different
stuff that we haven't really handled on
on any of our streams yet that I really
want to get to but I do need to go over
a little bit of what happened with all
these pull requests these awesome pull
requests that we got since so much has
changed so let me just bring this over
and show you so these are for pull
requests I'm just gonna give brief
descriptions of these obviously you can
go in yourself and see what has changed
oh if there's also a live stream going
on on Instagram so we do have someone
watching right now on Instagram so if
you want to see the code for this
Instagram stream go to free code camps
YouTube channel and you can see what's
going on on my screen okay so the first
pull requests so Sebastian basically
fixed all the the app trees so if you'll
see if you remember I didn't really have
things organized that well so I had
started to make I don't think I even
made a components folder yet I think I
did make a Styles folder but I still had
some Styles in our main source directory
so Sebastian went in native components
directory put everything in the Styles
directory that you know all our style
sheets put all the components in here so
it's a lot more organized definitely
more clean I actually need to move so
this is certain some later pull requests
so I need to move this into the
components as well but basically that
was just like super super helpful the
next and I'm sorry if I'm missing
anything from these pull requests I
apologize I'm just gonna try to get
through this quickly so he can get to
the code rohit made a i talked on friday
about it would be really cool to have a
component that depending on what you
passed in as props
it would make a card with basically any
potentially with anything that you would
normally have in a material design style
card so check this actually let me bring
it over from from n grok yeah and let me
let me give you the I always forget to
do this at the beginning so I have the N
grog server running so it looks like
maybe someone got on already I don't
know maybe it's just me is that one
person yeah it's probably just me I'm
gonna paste this in the live chat hey
everybody I see everyone's saying hi in
the live chat hey thanks for watching
everybody so there's the link if you
can't check out the live chat right now
it's this highlighted link right here
I'll leave it up on the screen for just
just a little bit longer give you a
chance to you put it in a few if you
want the URLs are there I understand why
they have to be a long string of numbers
like that because there's probably a lot
of them but not that easy to type in
alright so let me move this over now so
we can get back to it so basically if
you want to use if you want to be able
to see the site you know live as I'm
developing it go to that URL and if you
go there you'll be able to see cool
stuff like this okay so now I remember
what else Sebastian did he gave me
different placeholder images random ones
so I think like this is always going to
be architecture tech animals and
probably like nature some landscapes or
something so that's really cool let's
see what we keep good didn't refresh for
us oh well if it has refreshed since I
merged this pull request this morning so
it'll provide refresh again at some
point so just let me show you so this is
the card now so you can see this one has
all the options in here so we can have
you know the title with a little avatar
image the main image here and overlay
with the title just a title inside here
our action buttons are content so really
cool and then all this is controlled by
the props so if you want to check out
that component go ahead on github and
you can check it out in more depth we
will be using it as we go forward so
you'll see more of it but that was just
really awesome that was perfect exactly
what I was kind of envisioning for that
component so thank you and then we have
to pull requests from from Kevin and one
is you remember last week on Friday we
finished up with this this form alright
we had our form elements and the only
thing that I didn't like was the button
it's not it wasn't terrible but it just
wasn't it didn't have the effect that I
was used to with the other buttons
because we had used materialized CSS
before on previous projects and the
material UI button styles were just a
little different so now we have the
exact styles and it's really cool that
actually we can still use the same
component name but and you can see it in
the code but basically that component is
now wrapped in a materialized button
style component so just adds these this
effect on to it so I think this actually
looks better because of the mainly
because of the drop shadow or the box
shadow if you see it I don't know
depending on the video quality you could
probably see but anyway that's that's
exactly what what I was thinking of what
I wanted it to look like so that's
awesome and then also we have testing so
we now have a nightmare Jas and we have
some test setup through there and I'm
gonna be honest I have not done testing
like this other than just reading about
it or doing some a little bit of like a
tutorial on testing but I haven't
actually done any testing on my projects
so this would be the first time I'm
using that so I'm not even really sure
how to use it at this point but I'll be
figuring it out so I have one of the
tests up right now so it seems pretty
straightforward right so
this is for the homepage test obviously
home test is when we say it contains
Resource Center right so we're checking
to make sure it actually has the right
title that's cool
we're checking to make sure it's showing
six cards based on the class of the the
columns so it seems straightforward I'm
gonna have to read up more on on how to
do this now that we have it on the
project but really cool that this is on
here cuz after I saw this pull request I
remembered that I had said I was going
to try to do testing and then completely
forgot about it so sorry for forgetting
about it and thanks Kevin for the pull
request and putting it in alright so
this now looks good I mean we'll we'll
come back and add in the correct text
and everything in there when we go to
make this form actually work but right
now yawning I don't know why I'm yawning
I actually got a decent amount of sleep
last night this weekend was crazy
I basically coded like Friday all day
like I got him I went home from work
earlier but then just immediately
started coding and then all night and so
like 3:30 a.m. and then I went to sleep
woke up on Saturday and then coded all
day Saturday and took Sunday completely
off but I just I had a lot had a site
that I had done previously in a database
crashed on it and it was I just couldn't
figure it out I was insane so I ended up
just completely creating a new droplet
on digital ocean and making a lamp stack
installing WordPress put an SSL on it I
just made a new subdomain pointed it to
there and then pulled in that data
through WordPress API into a react site
like we did with our last project from
the new then
ooh drop that luckily I actually had the
development version of the WordPress
installation on a different server that
that I used just like manage some shared
hosting account with SiteGround and I
had never deleted it which which end up
being really good because I was able to
just export everything from there and
import it in so it took a lot of time
and it was pretty crazy and then I
decided hey let's like just update the
react installation too and I tried to
upgrade next and react to newer versions
and just completely broke it so for
hours that night the site was down
luckily it was in the middle of the
night and it's basically the the
audience is in the same time zone as me
so it probably was okay but I then I
needed to get the site back up and
running which is why I stayed up so late
so anyway just a heads up as this that
was what my weekend was like I'm sure
some of you have been through similar
things you know I guess it kind of
happens sometimes site breaks you gotta
fix it all right so let's go to I've got
a posters done don't really have much
okay service request form this is going
to be a little bit more kind of in-depth
in our other pages were so let me bring
up
there we go let me bring this over and
so we all can see what's going on here
so obviously this is gonna have a form
but it's gonna have a lot more form
inputs than our last form did and not
only that but it's gonna have some some
pages that we need to put in before that
so when I was first building this it was
requested of me that I make it so that
users can't just go they don't go
straight to the forum all right so the
idea was that users were supposed to
understand the process first before
actually requesting things from the
department so I did think that that was
going to be pretty annoying after a
while so I was able to put this skip to
form button so it's just a slight slight
annoyance of having one more clip but
click but you can skip to this form so
the actual form is is this so we're
gonna have a bunch of regular text
inputs some multi-line inputs we're
gonna have a date date picker and then a
file uploader then we're gonna have a
bunch of check boxes a submit button and
then we're gonna have a box here that's
going to control whether or not you can
submit the form so you have to check to
say that they've read the planning guide
all right all this form needs to be sent
the data needs to be sent to someone in
an email and then it also we need to
send a confirmation to the user saying
we've received your submission and then
all the data also needs to be sent to
our project management system and they
have a REST API that we'll do that with
so we're not gonna get into that today
that's gonna be a bigger project but at
least we can start to build some of it
out so let's build
let's see for this page yeah let's just
do this page first I do at least want to
show you what what else we're gonna have
so we're gonna have this this guy this
planning guide so we do right now I'll
have having two pages of it or three
pages so we have the planning guide page
one then it lists a bunch of services
then it lists the final page before you
get to the request form there's also
this other page of just terms so this is
a glossary page so I'm thinking about
maybe trying to combine some of these so
they're not pages a bunch of different
pages I think what happened at the time
when I was developing this was I I think
at one time early on I couldn't have
anything that required a scroll it was
really weird some of the stuff trying to
figure out how to do this and make it
work within you know the the system
which was called J ICS from a company
called Jenzabar so it was difficult
trying to work within that so I think
maybe that's why it ended up being
separated so if there's not really a
great reason why it's separated I don't
see why this page and then that third
page couldn't be combined but today
let's actually work on that form that
seems more interesting than just putting
in blocks of text so oops
alright so we're gonna have a lot I'm
gonna move this over to my other screen
and we're just gonna bring everything
into here and build this form
so there you go fuse service request
okay oh let me check out the live chat
as well I'm sorry I haven't really
looked at anything in the live chat
since I started taunt towing Laius hello
Jesse redux and Redux augur bring me
many difficulties where you have a
course to mention this maybe that's
something I'm interested in learning
more about so it's a possibility I don't
have I can't give you like officially
when that will be but once I learn it if
I feel confident enough to do a video
about it I will
Tunney mess it aside Jesse how are you
I'm doing pretty good are you going
if you need cos what Mac do you have
it's an iMac is it late maybe like late
2015 iMac early 2015 I can't remember
but it's it's an iMac I have a MacBook
Pro too
okay cool so Rowan says that this form
looks pretty good as it was so the form
that I just showed with you know having
it inside the card we'll see actually
let's let's think about that just for a
minute
do we want to keep this in the card you
know we had said with the previous form
that wasn't a card that we moved it and
just had it you know right on the on the
paper here in the back and not in a card
now this card will be we won't be
overlapping the header anymore because
we're not gonna have this giant thick
header so should we keep it in a card or
should we put it you know just inside
the page I don't know I kind of think if
we're gonna get away from having
everything in the cards maybe we
shouldn't have it in a card so I think
some of the issues that we talked about
last week still remain for this as well
and that it looks somewhat like a pop up
the way it is now this is not exactly
really what cards are for in material
design so I don't know I'm gonna I'm
actually I'm gonna leave it outside of a
card and see how it looks and then we
could always have the possibility of
just wrapping it in a card later on but
I would like to see how it looks not
being in a card because I do I agree I
think it looks it looks pretty good
right now but just for the sake of
consistency I want to see how it looks
outside of the car
all right so I'm going to I see there's
some more questions in the lad chat but
I'm going to work a little bit on this
and then I'll come back to that so if
you ask the question stick around I'll
get to it later on yeah so I'd at least
like to get most of this builds out
before I have to stop so if you didn't
catch it at the beginning this is all
the streams only gonna be about an hour
long okay I did have someone ask maybe
listen to comment over the weekend and I
don't know if I ever responded to him
I'll have to make sure I tried to
respond to as many comments as I could
this weekend
but I don't think I got to them all but
they had asked about why are all these
components like have like the class you
know component why not why aren't they
just like functional stateless
components and I mean the short answer
is like well a lot of these are just
placeholders right now and if it ends up
that we don't need them they have you
know their own state or anything if it's
possible to make them functional
components then you know we'll do that
but for right now it's just just a
placeholder and some of them will
definitely need to have more like this
form one will obviously need to have
more so so we'll leave it like that okay
so probably the best thing to do will be
to copy over some of this from
[Music]
another page let me see what was the
page that we just had probably the story
page this already does have some form
elements on it so this will be the best
and we do have some some of the imports
that we'll need we could just bring in
and let's pull in this whole container
okay
so we don't need any services actually
we will need so we do have some text
it's actually in the header now it just
says please use this form to request
services so I'm not gonna leave that
text in the header just because of the
way our headers definitely different for
this so we will have some text at the
top and right now I think this this is
actually a H it's in each - okay we'll
see what it's like it's an H to see if
it even makes any sense as an h2 I'm
gonna get rid of these paragraph tags
and put it in h2 and we're gonna say
okay now we can actually put in some of
our fields so we're gonna have a lot of
fields let's see so we are gonna have a
name email from Department and so one
two three four so I think we'll need for
regular text fields let's check out
material UI and see what they have in
terms of fields
okay you should I want to see okay I
just wanted to double-check and see like
your different types of fields how they
were controlled so it looks like it's
all controlled through through props
which is great so we can just copy and
paste our basic text field and then go
back through if we want to format
something I'm thinking you know I have a
field for a phone number right so we
probably only want to take numbers in
the phone number field you know things
like that I have a field for email so
maybe we should check that it's actually
an email so basic like form validation
stuff alright so we can take these and
copy then again because we need two more
and then from there we want
I have a lot of like large text
multi-line text fields I guess it's
better to have it in case users have a
lot to say some some of these fields
could be answered in less than you know
just a few words but I guess potentially
you might want to do more so let's leave
it sub 1 2 3 5 6 7 8 so we need 8
multi-line text fields so we have one
already
Sushi's need seven more so it's two
three four five six seven
this components going to be long me
quite quite large I I suspect
once it's finished then after that we
need a date picker and we need a file
uploader so let's check out
in a separate day there we go date
picker not a time alright so let's see
what we want
below the inputs I think I'm gonna go
with the modal yeah let's go with the
modal and we'll do it in portrait
that'll be close as to what we have
right now this is this is what we
currently have so
it won't be yeah it's not gonna be
exactly the same but I'm okay with that
I mean obviously we'll want to you know
customize the colors but I think it'll
actually end up being better I think I
like this better I mean there's certain
things about it I suppose that aren't
quite okay so you can pick the year okay
it looks like the the only thing that to
me is not gonna be as easy is the
ability to just pick the month here so
you actually have to looks like go
through a bit
but I don't really see that as a huge
huge problem okay so this this will work
this date picker will definitely work so
we're gonna have to bring in the date
picker
and let's bring in this woman
and
should have made the columns before but
I well so let's do a call them first
there we go alright and I'm gonna say
that if something to see what it looks
like ok cool
hmm I don't want them all the way across
so I had forgotten that I had these all
set to be full with so let's change that
right now
there we go so we wanted still to be s
slow but then we want to add an M right
was it M what are we doing up here yeah
M 6 so on medium screens we want this to
take up half the screen meaning 6 of our
12 columns so now let's say that and see
how it looks okay this is much more like
I wanted it to look not really
yeah not too bad okay cool but I didn't
expect I think I missed I missed one too
I think I was supposed to have eight of
these so I must have missed one
it's kind of embarrassing that I
couldn't count to eight in front of
everybody on YouTube all right so that's
that's better I'm still not like what
there's something about this that just
does not look as nice and what is it
maybe they just look too big
actually let me check this for him so I
just want to see what the color is on
this font
yeah I don't think I wanted I want it to
be a little bit
okay I think this font maybe is too
light so I'm probably gonna end up
changing the font I'm gonna finish you
know creating our fields before I go in
and do that but I think we did have a
darker did we have a darker font all
right no I'm not sure I want to see what
font I had for this
all right so I'm going to check the
color that I'm using for this one I
actually don't like either because it's
it is an actual gray hex color I'd
rather have black with set like I don't
know maybe 54% transparency so I'll have
to look after we get the layout done I'm
gonna look at a project I did within the
last few months that I know I did form
stuff with and I was happy with the the
color so I'll just go back and check
that color but I think that's that's
pretty much probably what's bothering
any maybe these are a little bit longer
than I'm used to but also probably
better to see it with the real words
here instead of having them all be the
same let's see what else we need so we
need our file upload and then a bunch of
check boxes so hopefully there's a file
uploader here let's see
not seeing it
it's okay if I'm missing it and someone
has experience with with this framework
material UI if it's in the framework
please let me know otherwise I'm just
gonna pull it from materialized CSS
because I know that they have it and
I've used it before it's gonna look look
through this menu mmm excuse me again
just more yawning so here's our check
boxes which we will need those
let me check the text field just really
quickly I doubt it'll be here but it's
possible yeah yeah definitely not there
okay let's go to our check boxes then so
we're gonna skip that for now I'll just
put in something as a placeholder and
we'll just need to put that in so let me
just double up on this date picker for
now
I don't know I think I keep saying
download button and it's upload I want
people to upload things I don't know why
I kept saying download all right so we
want okay and I remember this so we're
gonna use these checkboxes and I'm
definitely gonna use these ones but I
may change how the style of them at some
point because it's definitely not
exactly what we have so if you see what
we're doing here it's a different
different effect and maybe I'm just used
to this because I've been using it but I
kind of like this effect and let's see
what this one I'm pretty sure this one
is actually closer to what you're
supposed to use with material design but
this one is closer to what we've been
using at the University for for all of
our forms so at this point I think I
would kind of just want to go with this
but we'll see that'll be one of those
things that if we have time to do it
we'll do it otherwise I think that you
know this will definitely be acceptable
I mean this looks good it's just not
gonna be exactly consistent with
everything else we've done so we'll just
add that to the list of maybe for now
let's see where do we have the label at
okay so we want the label on the right
check box on the left okay
I said check we're gonna import our
checkbox
all right so you have the checkbox
and we'll pull in
do we need these styles
I'm just wondering whether or not I
should bring in these styles but really
all we're doing styles checkbox is just
a margin bottom 16 let's say I'm not
sure if I even want that margin so what
we're gonna bring it in will leave out
the style and see what kind of margin we
have and we can always you know add in a
margin later on right now I just want to
kind of see how it looks like on the
page so
probably I think I want columns two
columns with a bunch of the check boxes
inside so we're gonna want another div
with a class name just like we've been
doing not really doing anything creative
with our classes right now with our
column classes so I'm just gonna add a
few more of these just to give us an
idea of what they're gonna look like and
oops didn't get that top
and put this here let's save that and
see what it looks like oh and I forgot
to take out the style so it's gonna be
easier for me just to add so that was
checkbox and I think at this point so
let's do that
whatever want to put this cost inside
here right we'll see if it works in a
second
no don't want to put it outside don't
want to put it inside the render
function will not work because I didn't
put this now oh sweet it did work cool
all right not bad
see that that other thing next with 2:59
you die
cool
actually this this effect is kind of
growing on me I like that little ripple
a circular ripple effect I don't know
what do you think let me know in the
live chat and in the comments do you
like this first effect which is
basically like the Box completely goes
away and then there's a check or do you
like the circular ripple effect
all right so let me know I'll give it we
don't need to decide right now we can I
mean right now this is going to be in
there and maybe we'll change it later
but I am just at least interested in
what you all think about this okay so
the only thing we need to add I mean
other than making sure that we have
these I'm not worried about all these
yet because before this goes live this
is going to change so I'm not gonna
worry about whether I have the same
number as on the current list because
we're we're gonna take out some things
maybe add things I'm not sure the only
thing I'm missing is that last checkbox
here so let's just add that in and then
I'll take your questions
I wonder if and get away with putting it
right there what it'll look like it
definitely needs a little little padding
but that's about about where we want it
okay cool well we basically have the
layout for this the only thing that we
didn't get done is this file upload so
we're gonna have to pull this unless
material you I have something that I'm
missing we're gonna pull all the code
from materialized and we're gonna use
that for our file upload and that should
look good I've used it before so yeah
that's it not bad this was actually the
page that I thought would take the most
time and it it hasn't been too bad now
what will take a lot of time is actually
making this thing functional and do all
the behind the scenes things that we
wanted to do in terms of sending data
where it needs to go that'll take a
while but at least the layouts done and
I'm not I don't really like the look of
this right now so we'll see maybe we'll
do something with this but all the
pieces are there and we'll just kind of
shift them around a bit as we need to
okay so let me commit this let me check
the status see yep that's what we've
checked all right that's what we've
worked on
okay so now this is all on github and
she all can see everything that we've
done see all the code now actually let
me let me bring over or is it that
I did want to see I want to see if we
got any new images now so I mention the
beginning I was hoping this would
refresh and we get an images but didn't
refresh all right let me check the live
chat now I'll try to get to as many
questions as I can but right around you
know when I hit the hour mark for this
video so that's in about 15 minutes
then I'm gonna have to wrap things up
hopefully I can get through all your
questions and now looks like we did have
a few people in the Instagram stream but
it looks like they left
I always forget about that stream and I
wonder if people just happen to stumble
upon it I wonder if they even know
what's going on since they can't see see
the code I don't really know any other
way to solve that I can't really take
the time to check that frequently okay
so Jung asks I'm trying to start
learning web development any suggestions
where I should start from free code
can't so I really I mean I realize I'm
streaming for the free code Kent YouTube
channel but I really do think free code
camp is a great starting point if you're
just getting into web development even
if you already have the basics down
there's still a lot to do in free code
camps so that's a great place other than
that if you happen to not really like
free code camp for some reason code
Academy also is very beginner friendly
anything that has browser-based
learning I think is very user friendly
because you don't get stuck trying to
set up your development environment and
you can actually get to do some you know
HTML CSS JavaScript and see how you like
it before you have to commit
- like install a note on your machine
and you know getting that up and running
I don't know about you but I remember
when I was first installed a note on my
machine um years of god I don't know how
many years ago was but it wasn't very
intimidating and it was like am I gonna
break my computer here like what what am
i doing so that can be intimidating so
those two resources are great there's
also some YouTube channels that are good
for beginners so learn code Academy is a
good YouTube channel that has some nice
stuff that I think is beginner friendly
they have some advanced stuff too but
and then dev tips
it's another YouTube channel that has
some pretty good things for beginners
it's more geared towards CSS and less
you know you you get you get some
JavaScript but less JavaScript you know
then then you'll get in learned code
Academy and I don't really have a lot on
my personal channel yet but I do plan
hope hopefully at some point I can get
some of those beginner tutorials up that
I want to I'd like to include so I
definitely I need to do some tutorials
so this is just for a timeline for you
all since I've been saying I was going
to do these videos for a long time now I
hope to have either some interns or
student workers in the fall so coming up
like making a month and I really want to
make those videos so that every time I
get new workers I don't have to train
them continually on the same basic
things I mean I still I'm gonna train
them on things but there's a lot of
really basic stuff that doesn't require
me like personally taking the time to go
through and that I want to do those in
videos so it's going to be things like
setting up your development
environment basic you know get commands
how to use github just a lot of those
things that I use in my workflow and
that anybody that wants to work in this
department and work on the projects that
we're working on will need to know to be
able to contribute so those videos will
probably be coming soon so assuming that
I do have some students so I have some
interest there's some students that are
interested in learning and coming here
doing some work and learning more so
hopefully hopefully that will happen and
there'll be an added benefit of there
being some some tutorial videos on my
channel for you all to check out if you
like but aside from that there's a lot
of great stuff on me or the other the
other places that I mentioned are really
good and a lot of those places are where
I learned
okay it looks like at the beginning when
I was asking about keeping this form in
the cart or not a few of you actually
said keep it in the card so I'll keep
that in mind well maybe I'll put it in
it won't be too hard to put it inside a
card so we can always put it back in the
card if if we need to suppose where it
says hey man shout out from Africa hey
thanks for watching
Philip asks when you work at home do you
have an office or do you have to work
where your kids are so actually I I just
did kind of a different setup so for the
the first few streams that I had done
from home I was actually set up like
right in my living room uh-huh
so it was not really the best place now
when I was working my wife had taken the
kids somewhere else
so it worked out but if the kids had
been there it would have been hard to
work now I have worked like that before
and I just put headphones on and I
turned the music up really loud and I've
actually been so focused on my work that
I've had like the neighbor stopped by
came in my house sat down three feet
away from me at a table talked to my
wife for an hour and then left and I
didn't even know she was there so I can
focus enough to make that work but I
recently moved to my basement in my
laundry room and and that's a little bit
more private and the kids are less
likely to come down there the bad news
is it's really noisy when the washer and
dryer are running and it's also a
basement so there's not really when I
was in my living room I could open up I
have a lot of windows there I could open
up a lot of the windows I'd hear the
birds and get a nice breeze blowing
through so it felt like I was outside
almost so there's a much nicer
environment so we'll see how that goes
I've always kind of thought about making
a legit
office but right now I do so much work
you know in you know in the office here
at the university that it doesn't really
make sense for me to have Home Office
right now my um is not that big I'm
actually running out of space so as you
all probably know from previous dreams I
have four kids and right now there are
two bedrooms for the four kids and which
I guess isn't too bad but they're not
really big bedrooms so I can't really
take one of those and make it my office
right now then we'd have one bedroom for
all four kids so so we'll see that there
have to be some construction involved if
I were to have my own home office which
isn't out of the question it may it may
happen
okay Roland says material design specs
don't mention this anywhere of it even
on Google's properties forms are usually
in a card okay that's good to know
Patrick doesn't think it'll look like
you know okay so if you're not sure what
we're talking about right now earlier on
we were debating whether or not to have
this form in a card like it is here or
to put it directly on the page and it
seems like so far everyone has said that
they wanted in the card and not on the
page so we may end up moving it into the
card I was worried that it wasn't really
you know proper material design style to
put this in a card but evidently Google
is using it in that way and you know
putting forms and cards like that so off
to check it out now that I think about
it the new settings tab in Chrome I
think that's I haven't been there in a
long time but I thought they switched
materials on yeah they did so the new
settings tab in chrome is everything's
in cards it's not exactly a forum but
it's it's close enough so this is what
I'm talking about
settings I mean there are form elements
within this so yeah that that seems kind
of legit like it could it could work so
it may end up doing that
okay so Kevin says I think it's better
in the paper for consistency sake also
okay so we do have some some differing
opinions here off to think about it
Rohan says keep the background off
whitish it looks better that way yeah it
does do I have to see what the
background was I thought I had it off it
is off right white right now right it's
I guess whatever the default is for
material UI is what it is right now
which should be slightly off off white I
think yeah Sebastian said move the
button component to the component folder
I will I will move it in there I don't
want to just move it right now because I
don't have time to make sure that it's
it's properly I'll have to change the
import to where it's in I think it's
only in one view right now actually now
it's in two right we just used it again
so I want to make sure I have enough
time to change those when I move it but
I will move it alright Roland says you
can use h4 h5 for description just use
h1 for the service request form yeah
that makes sense maybe I'll go do that I
am gonna kind of change this a bit and
make it look better and if we end up
putting this in a card then we'll have
to see what we do about this
Jordan asks why the early stream
imperative associates a meeting yeah
basically I have a meeting at 2:00 and I
was supposed to have another meeting at
3:00 that ended up getting canceled so I
but I figured it'd better just do the
early stream that way I know I get it in
in case the the other meeting runs long
I don't expect it to but I really have
no idea how long the other meetings
gonna be so I was safer to just stream
early let's see if someone in the live
stream a Malia how's it going
so someone someone who used to work in
my department actually just watched on
on Instagram so those cool she did web
stuff too so that was good she moved on
and and now I think she has a better job
than all of us in the department so I'm
happy for
okay so Kevin says there is something in
materiai that seat that works for a file
picker hasn't tested it yet and I put he
put the link in okay awesome off to
check that out
Oh Sebastian said I can add type file to
a text field
well that will that work will that look
I'll have to check it out later right
now yeah I only have another minute left
but office it off to check out how that
that looks okay Umberto likes the
circular riffle so - Sebastian okay
since the rotate box thing looks choppy
yeah I think it looks a little bit
better in other implementations that was
one of my early implementations of it
but yeah it is choppier for sure
okay it looks like everybody alright
pretty much everybody likes the ripple
effect on the checkbook so I think I
will end up sticking with that and I
think it'll be fun I'm not super upset
if I have a slightly different effect on
checkboxes for different sites as I go
back and update old sites I can always
just change it if I need to so I think
I'll keep it with the ripple effect
Vinicio says Jessie do you think
JavaScript would be the best language to
begin man I don't I'm not sure if it
depends on what you want to do if you
know you want to do web development then
yeah go with JavaScript because that's
that's what you're going to be using if
you want to just get more into like
programming in general then something
else like like Python would be maybe
easier to pick up I think you know a lot
of places start with Python so yeah I
did but it does it just depends on what
you want to do so I kind of I started
with JavaScript for the most part and it
turned out all right for me I guess so
it's definitely you know it's doable a
lot of people start with JavaScript but
I think Python would also be a good
alternative if you weren't if you didn't
really want to get into web design
specifically then maybe Python would be
better
okay cool so Patrick says the file
picker is in the docks under the race
button stuff
I want to see this
unless I'm not seeing it maybe I'm
looking in the wrong place
there we go all right cool
it's just the first one okay cool so you
just wrap the input inside the race
button all right good to know so this is
what we use then and awesome awesome
that'll work thank you
Patrick for find a desk it's kind of a
little weird the place where it I don't
I mean I don't know but that just wasn't
like obvious to me that I would find the
file input under race button oh well it
seems like it would make more sense if
they had forms as a category and then on
the drop-down you had all the different
types I think it would make it you clean
it up a lot more you think they're
taking full requests for their
documentation probably they might not
care those since they're coming out with
a new version for the old version but I
think it would be better better
organized like that
okay cool so in regard to what we're
talking about earlier with me trying to
get work done with all my kids and no
office Philip says I'm right there with
you I have three kids and doing side
projects is challenging yeah you need
CEO says you have four kids that's
awesome I have two little girls yeah
that's cool isn't it
having kids is it's like one of the
hardest things I've ever done but it's
also one of those awesome things I've
ever done and my kids are still little
I'm sure it even it gets harder and and
more awesome as they get older Ellen
says office in a shed or garage says you
might have to do something about the
network but it might work actually
that's that is a good idea
my sheds in terrible shape so there's no
way I can put any electronic stuff in my
shed cuz the roof has holes in it but I
really really want to add a girl I don't
currently don't have a garage so I
really would like a garage and maybe I
should keep that in mind if I do end up
building a garage to make a space for an
office there
okay kevin says on the card /page debate
there is a paper component that just
adds the depth effect okay cool I have
to check that out so I won't actually
have to like put it in in a card we can
just add some depth to the paper
Rowan says meetings the non-technical
bane of developers that's for sure I
like I just can't take all these
meetings there's so many meetings and
like some days I feel like I get no
coding done because there's too many
meetings and you you have to get ready
for a meeting and then you have the
meeting and then after the meeting you
usually have to do something based on
what happened in the meeting it's just
like and then there's all the emails
back and forth trying to find a good
time to schedule the meeting for its so
it's just crazy
all the time spent on meetings I think I
mentioned this before in a stream but
just in case I haven't I
I would love to make like a scheduling
app or like maybe a Chrome extension
that put automatically on your calendar
the price of the meeting so it would
just take how many people are in the
meeting and then based on like an
average salary or something per hour it
would tell you how much that meeting is
gonna cost and then I think there would
be less meetings because people wouldn't
just say like okay I'm gonna have like
10 people in this meeting and we're
gonna meet for two hours instead they'd
say like wow this is a $4,000 meeting
maybe we don't need this this $4,000
meeting right now anyway
I I think it'd be a good idea I don't
and I'm it's not like I made this idea
up I'm pretty sure that I saw this
somewhere in the internet that someone
had done something similar so I don't
want to take credit for it but I have no
idea where I read it
how everyone says meetings discussing
previous meetings those are true beauty
oh my goodness yeah I hate when I have a
meeting about something that we've
already decided in previous meetings and
we're just trying to remember what we
decided in that meeting since like
especially when like I remember for sure
what happened in that meeting and it's
just a matter of trying to convince
everybody else that we actually did
agree to that thing it's especially
frustrating when it's about some some
feature on something I'm building
Tiffany said that meeting ideas
hilarious I know wouldn't that be good
right and I feel free any of you to
steal that idea and build something with
that and if you do then I I will use it
but maybe oh I've actually like done it
on paper like I've been in a meeting
before like calculating how much
meetings cost and then I'll usually just
like text somebody or write it on a
paper and show somebody next to me and
we'll we'll smile about it in the heat
all right well I made it through all the
questions and I think I've gone over the
time I said I was gonna gonna go so what
else isn't it I'm always doing that so I
really do have to go now because I want
to get to the meeting and make sure I'm
prepared for that so thank you all for
for watching especially with the the
time change that was kind of late notice
so I appreciate y'all being ok with that
and joining in and participating
especially thank you to everyone who
submitted pull requests over the weekend
super helpful it's making this project
just really awesome and I'll be back
tomorrow hopefully at the proper time
tomorrow which is 2 p.m. eastern time
until then I hope you all have a great
day